but if you go into any school all the
boys are dating all the girls if you go
into any workplace
and women are together look at the
YouTube world every YouTubers
that's how it works but the problem is
you guys are only looking at like well
look at Tinder where it's five men to
one I didn't actually agree on college
campuses it's similar I would say it's
similar on college campuses there's like
a select group of men that tend to do
very well no hold on wait no no wait you
okay what you just said is a highlight
of why I think you're not either
engaging no no wait because you said men
do very well
can I just I said a select group of men
you said a selective so for example like
athletes no one athlete is not dating
five women a select group of men they
might have sex but that's why I say it's
important to distinguish sex between
relationships an elite group of men can
a lot of women sure